[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale préparé par les équipes de tv 78
nous sommes le lundi à 4 octobre voici
les titres de cette édition
les jeunes de l'association mosaïque se
préparait à rouler contre le cancer fin
octobre douze jeunes partiront des
sables d'olonne pour rejoindre et que
vit à vélo un événement pour lutter
contre le cancer à quelques jours de la
nouvelle élection municipale à trappes
othman nasri candidat de droite poursuit
sa campagne tête de liste de rassembler
pour trapil candidate aux côtés de guy
malandain et moustapha larbaoui
respectivement de gauche et sans
étiquette et puis premier volet du
dossier de la rédaction il est consacré
cette semaine au plan relance dans les
yvelines 500 millions d'euros ont été
reversés dans le département en un an
et puis cette information annoncée par
le ministère de la justice jeudi 30
septembre la construction d'un centre
pénitentiaire à magnanville le but de la
structure prévue pour 2027 lutter contre
la surpopulation notamment à celle de
bois d'arcy à 161 % de sa capacité
d'accueil la maison d'arrêt à devrait
accueillir 700 personnes une pétition en
ligne a été créée vendredi contre la
construction du centre pénitentiaire
elle a déjà récolté plus de mille huit
cent cinquante signatures
[Musique]
l'association départementale
yvelines infos jeunes travaillent auprès
des jeunes yvelinois elle lit elle lutte
notamment contre le décrochage scolaire
professionnelle laurence cousin vous
vous êtes avec nous m'ont soir bonsoir
donc vous êtes la directrice de
l'association tout à fait il ya donc
trente structures sur le territoire vous
vous êtes basé à montigny le bretonneux
votre objectif c'est quoi c'est de
sensibiliser les jeunes leur faire
connaître finalement les offres du
territoire oui complètement alors on est
déjà un réseau national donc l'idée déjà
la première chose c'est de s'adresser
aux jeunes localement c'est pour ça
qu'on a un maillage territorial assez
important et c'est de répondre aux
jeunes de les informer sur tous les
sujets qui les intéressent alors c'est
vrai que le premier des sujets c'est
l'insertion de socioprofessionnels bien
sûr mais au delà ça peut être aussi les
jeunes qui vont bien peuvent venir nous
voir
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya une
méconnaissance finalement des
dispositifs sur le territoire mis en
place oui même au niveau national
d'ailleurs le dispositif ingénieux une
solution c'est juste moi aussi pour
faire connaître tous les dispositifs qui
se présentent aux jeunes et qui logent
souvent qu'ils méconnaissent et pourquoi
selon vous justement certains jeunes se
retrouvent à la rentrée finalement sans
solution ou alors en situation de
décrochage alors ça dépend à près de
kehl jaune on parle notamment pour ceux
qui sont post bac il ya donc un
dispositif qui s'appelle parcours sup
donc il ya différents pour processus et
souvent ceux qui se retrouvent sans
solution c'est ceux pour qui les voeux
n'ont pas été réalisés donc ils n'ont
pas eu de place dans l'école de leur
choix
donc après une septembre donc c'est vrai
mais après on l'est on les accompagne à
ce moment là on demande la rentrée pour
essayer de retrouver finalement une
alternative tout à fait puis après il ya
aussi la catégorie de ceux qui qui
recherche une entreprise parce qu'ils
veulent faire un une formation en
alternance et l'école c'est bien d'avoir
mais sans signature d'un contrat de
travail on ne peut pas intégrer l'école
en tout cas c'est plus compliqué il faut
il faudra l'école et l'employeur pour
les formations en alternance par exemple
et est ce que vous pensez vous avez
l'impression que finalement cette crise
sanitaire qu'on a vécu et est conviée
encore actuellement à accélérer ce
processus ou la route à amplifier ce
processus décrochage des jeunes
oui alors le décrochage c'est à dire
qu'une porte d'un projet professionnel
et ce qui est important ce qu'on peut
noter en tout cas suite à ses paires de
confinement d'incertitude c'est aussi le
moral des jeunes circulent quand on
n'est pas bien dans sa tête quand on
n'est pas bien ses baskets si je puis
dire forcément son avion ne voit pas
forcément il n'est pas linéaire et on ne
sait pas forcément ce qu'on veut faire
il ya des jeunes aussi qui se sont
isolés qui étaient isolés et donc qui
n'ont pas forcément été vers les
professionnels même si on avait des
modalités d'information par téléphone ou
autre certains en fait du coup ce sont
encore plus isolé et voilà ils sont un
peu pessimiste sur sur la suite de leur
parcours est donc là pour ces jeunes
sans alternative en tout cas en cette
nouvelle rentrée il y à une opération
vous l'avez mentionné qui va être lancée
ça s'appelle des solutions pour la
rentrée est ce que vous nous expliquer
déjà en quoi ça consiste cet événement
alors c'est un événement je veux dire
qui est récurrent qu'on appelait sos
contrer mais qu'on avait estimé un petit
peu alarmiste c'est un peu négatif en
tout cas sur l'intitulé mais
effectivement qui existait déjà dans le
réseau depuis quelques années le
dispositif va en fait c'est du dating
c'est tout simplement parce qu'on a
formé j'aime tout au long de l'année
mais là c'est un temps fort où on met en
relation sur le territoire les offres
donc et les structures qui proposent des
offres et les jeunes qui peuvent
justement s'adresser à ces structures
pour avoir plus d'informations et
pourquoi pas décrocher un contrat un
contrat en alternance une place en école
dans une école ou bien les missions de
deux volontaires par exemple
s'engager sur le territoire et donc ça
pour vous c'est un jet à dire un salon
est plutôt cédé forum finalement qui
sont nécessaires en tout cas aujourd'hui
qui en fait on en a besoin les jeunes en
ont besoin de ces forums les jeunes en
ont besoin je vois aussi les
professionnels parce qu'on l'a fait
l'année dernière dans une plaine dans un
contexte sanitaire qui était qui était
aussi assez incertain et je pense qu'on
avait tous eu plaisir à se retrouver et
c'est vrai qu'elle web qu'à un outil
formidable mais un jeune c'est vrai que
voilà validé sur l'orientation trouver
une place c'est pas forcément sur le web
qu'on le fait est là pour le coup c'est
vrai c'est d'avoir l'humain là je pense
qu'on peut pas on peut pas remplacer
l'humain et l'échangent qu'on peut avoir
et c'est comme ça souvent qu'on réussit
à avoir une place qu'on trouve une place
c'est parce qu'on a rencontrés on a
changé avec un interlocuteur s'est bien
passé et pour le coup après s'est
montrée positive dans le système soit de
l'éducation nationale soit soit de
l'emploi et pour parler peut-être un peu
du programme qu'est ce qui est prévu
justement sur ces différents forums qui
vont avoir lieu c'est pas il ya aussi
peut-être un accompagnement n'y a pas
que des offres ya des jobs vous m'avez
vous m'avez dit tout à l'heure oui 3 r
c'est le même format pour les trois
dates sur les trois bassins différents
donc c'est la formation l'emploi et
l'engagement donc ça c'est
aussi tous les toutous tous les
partenaires qui accompagnent donc c'est
les missions locales pôle emploi saint
quentin en yvelines service emploi tous
ceux qui sont là aussi au quotidien pour
accompagner les jeunes dans leur
parcours dans leur construction de
parcours pour justement que avant ou
après il puisse continuer à être
accompagné par des professionnels ça
c'est vraiment important quelquefois ils
pensent qu'ils ont tous sur internet met
à avoir un professionnel qui a du réseau
qui va connaître les opportunités sur le
territoire un moment donné ses ordres
plus pour les jeunes et du coup sur
place pour retrouver peut-être aussi du
volontariat pour les personnes qui veut
faire peut-être du service civique du
bénévolat complètement ça c'est un
masque cancale on tient beaucoup parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya des jeunes pour
qui justement ils ont tellement peur de
rater un an comme ils disent bien
souvent qu'ils sont prêts à faire un peu
tout et n'importe quoi alors que
franchement faire une
s'engager pour une mission d'intérêt
général auprès d'une structure une
association ou une institution
c'est un vrai c'est une valeur ajoutée
dans leur cv et même humainement c'est à
dire que ça va les faire mûrir et du
coup ça va faire aussi mûrir leur projet
professionnel parce qu'on est là aussi
pour les accompagner lors d'une mission
en tant que volontaire ça peut être
aussi localement mais aussi à
l'international puisque on les informe
aussi sur les dispositifs de mobilité
européenne et internationale
on le rappelle donc si vous êtes sans
solution pour cette nouvelle rentrée
scolaire rendez vous aux différents
forums organisés donc par l'association
départementale
yvelines infos jeunes ça se passera le 6
octobre à aubergenville le 7 octobre
archère et puis le 13 octobre à
elancourt à savoir que le pass est
obligatoire mais sur place on peut faire
des tests c'est lui on y tenait beaucoup
c'est à dire que les jeunes qui
n'auraient pas qu'ils n'auraient pas été
vaccinés ou qui n'ont pas les moyens de
se voit là de faire une par le passé le
test pardon pcr sur place y aura la
croix rouge qui peut qui leur permettra
de faire le test les voilà exactement
tout à fait merci beaucoup leur ans
cousin d'avoir été avec nous je le
rappelle est directrice divine infos
jeunes
[Musique]
douze jeunes vont partir à vélo des
sables d'olonne jusqu'à et quevilly ce
sera pour lutter contre le cancer à
l'origine du projet l'association
mosaïque samedi 2 octobre une journée
avec eux vit à vélo était organisée pour
promouvoir ce projet le reportage de
céline charles et ses liens 400 go
c'était une journée en soutien au projet
mosaïque roule contre le cancer
l'association mosaïque centre social à
ecquevilly se lance pour la troisième
édition dans un défi à vélo du 25 au 30
octobre cette année laventure par des
sables d'olonne pour se terminer dans la
livrée noir nous avons contre le cancer
ca a vu le jour suite à l'initiative de
jeunes en 2018 suite au décès de leur
camarade et se sont mobilisés entre
guillemets on n'a rien pu faire pour
pour notre camarade qui est décédé
comment on peut accompagner ou soutenir
les autres et jeunes ont donc établi un
parcours pour sensibiliser la population
dans d'autres villes comme nantes angers
ou le mans on va s'arrêter dans
différentes villes donc en tout cas je
croyais à cette ville dans chaque ville
où on s'arrête on va rencontrer des
jeunes on va sensibiliser le conseil
participe à ce projet parce que c'est là
une façon de lutter contre une bonne
cause et
balas et cancer et c'est quelque chose
qui nous tient à coeur et pour faire
connaître ce projet osé cuvillo à des
ateliers étaient organisés comme en
atelier réparation un atelier vélo
smoothie ou encore une balade par enfant
à vélo l'objectif de cette journée a dit
double deux premiers ça va être de
sensibiliser à tout ce qui va être la
sécurité routière de transport en vélo
et inciter des gens à faire du vélo est
deuxième à une cause qui est noble
qu'est le cancer et donc on en revient
aux aigles contre le cancer donc
vraiment sensibiliser la population à ce
que ces deux concerts pendant six jours
douze jeunes dès que vivront parcourir
600 km une cagnotte li ti a été ouverte
pour soutenir le projet
et puis pour rappel dans le même cadre
l'annuel campagne d'octobre rose qui
lutte contre le cancer du sein est
lancée depuis vendredi un mois pour
sensibiliser au dépistage mais aussi
récolter des fonds pour la recherche
plusieurs événements font donc
organisées notamment dans le département
au programme course conférences ou
encore journée de sensibilisation
plus d'informations sur le site du
comité départemental de la ligue contre
le cancer
en politique à présent à quelques jours
de la nouvelle élection municipale de
trappes la liste rassembler pour trap
organisé une réunion publique
l'événement a pris place à l'école jean
jaurès de la ville ce mardi 28 septembre
c'était à 19h30 othman nas route tête de
liste avec guy malandain étaient
présents pour défendre leur candidature
à la proche du nouveau scrutin pour
élire le maire de la ville de trappes
othman nasro guy malandain et mustapha
al harbaoui ont donné rendez vous aux
trappistes mardi 28 septembre à l'école
jean jaurès une union républicaine à
trois visages pour un programme commun
je porte un certain nombre d'idées
depuis des années sur le renforcement de
la police municipale pour assurer la
sécurité et la tranquillité des
trappistes sur la défense des locataires
face aux bailleurs quand cela ne
respecte pas les règles sur la baisse de
la taxe foncière pour la rapprocher des
villes voisines sur la nécessité d'avoir
de la mixité y compris dans nos
commerces pour avoir des commerces
diversifiée et des professionnels de
santé qui s'installe rassemblés pour
trappe une liste qui voit sa lle des
hommes politiques de droite et de gauche
les trois candidats ont souhaité mettre
de côté leurs divergences jupe à changer
une vie politique je vais te prenez
comme exemple tout à l'heure des
présidentielles on votera pas la même
chose mais la situation a dit elle ce
qui est essentiel c'est la ville de
trappes ses habitants ce sont d'amener
la dynamique et puis il ya la sérénité
qui doit revenir pour qu'on reprenne
comme on vivait yahia 12 il ya deux ans
une soixantaine de militants et
habitants s'est rendu sur place ils sont
venus poser des questions ou soutenir
les candidats j'attends une chose c'est
qu'on rassemble la ville qu'on rassemble
tous les habitants les trappistes qu'on
laisse personne au bord du chemin au ban
de la honte aider toutes les populations
c'est à dire d'avoir les jeunes
les personnes âgées les personnes en
situation de handicap et les classes
moyennes et les classes enfin les
personnes lambda comme moi attrape le
nouveau scrutin aura lieu les 10 et 17
octobre prochains
c'est le retour du 7-8 dossier sur tv 78
on commence cette saison avec le plan
relance dans les yvelines premier sujet
de la semaine un bilan du déploiement de
ce programme dans le département plus de
500 millions d'euros ont été attribués à
trois thématiques l'écologie la
compétitivité et la cohésion à des
territoires les détails dans ce
reportage de nicolas landry
[Musique]
et puis dans le cadre de l'innovation la
nouvelle édition du salon hit onomie
2021 et lancer la cinquième édition
prend place aux mureaux mais aussi en
ligne proposé des solutions innovantes
pour les personnes âgées ou en situation
de handicap
au programme conférences exposants et
nouvelles technologies nous reviendrons
sur ce salon mercredi dans le cadre du
7-8 société
[Musique]
et puis côté culture à présent samedi 2
octobre c'était la nuit blanche en ile
de france plusieurs événements étaient
organisés dans les yvelines comme
c'était le cas au musée des portes
départemental maurice denis
exceptionnellement ouverts jusqu'à une
heure du matin
le reportage de célia gars tsongo et
céline charles
plongée dans l'obscurité muni d'une
lampe torche les visiteurs de
l'événement vision nocturne proposée au
musée départemental maurice denis ont pu
découvrir les oeuvres sous un autre
aspect c'est vraiment l'idée de
bousculer un peu notre musée à la
réouverture en proposant de voir notre
musée autrement et c'est aussi une
manière de combattre cette idée des
musées comme lieu passéiste au contraire
on veut affirmer les musées comme des
lieux de vie comme des lieux de passage
et des lieux également ouvert à l'art
contemporain
c'est la première fois que le musée
maurice denis participent à la nuit
blanche evènement franciliens dédié à la
création contemporaine durant une nuit
au programme ce soir là autre que la
déambulation nocturne une compagnie de
danse est intervenu au milieu des
oeuvres ce soir en fait un petit
animations du musée pendant la nuit
avec des extraits de pièces en fait
c'était court extrait de pièce de notre
répertoire qu'on a essayé de faire
résonner avec des oeuvres du musée la
compagnie de poésie demain des ménages
également présente à créer un corpus de
poèmes autour du thème vision nocturne
et en correspondance avec les oeuvres du
musée et intervenir en peluche dans un
cadre comme celui là avec des avec des
peintures c'est c'est vraiment ça
apporte encore à la magie de de la chose
qu'on attend de la soirée ce que je sois
un bon moment de partage autour de la
peinture et de la poésie
l'exposition maurice denis bonheur rêver
est également à découvrir en journée
jusqu'au 29 mai prochain
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi dont quelques
instants retrouvez miquel et demi
d'euros à la présentation de votre
magazine sportif très bonne soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]